en mai un vol de 25 heures sans
carburant c'est le défi que tentent de
relever en ce moment l'équipe de
l'explorateur bertrand piccard
depuis ce matin un appareil expérimental
propulsé grâce à l'énergie solaire
survolent la suisse
anne charline anbar dans le monde des
avions solar impulse a le gabarit d'une
libellule un poids plume de 1600 kg qui
n'a que pour seul carburant l'énergie
solaire c'est vraiment un moment spécial
très important toute l'équipe attend ça
depuis le début depuis presque sept ans
partis ce matin solar impulse tourner en
rond au-dessus de la suisse à une
vitesse de 35 km heure pour réaliser
l'exploit
il ne devrait toucher terre que demain
matin 25 heures de vol de jour comme de
nuit
un défi qui met à rude épreuve le
prototype croise les doigts on avance
dans l'inconnu taf
rien n'est certain nat santiago
certaines thèses déjà connu en 1999 pour
son tour du monde en ballon
bertrand piccard et son équipe espèrent
cette fois faire de même avec solar
impulse d'ici 2013 au gré des vents et
des 12000 cellules photovoltaïques
disposés sur les ailes
mais on commence d'abord par l'un des
plus beaux paris mariant la science et
l'écologie solar impulse a décollé tôt
ce matin de payerne en suisse pour un
vol expérimental de 25 heures
l'avion solaire imaginé par
l'explorateur bertrand piccard doit
voler sans carburant
la grande question c'est de savoir s'il
va pouvoir tenir y compris pendant la
nuit
nicolas chateauneuf sur la piste un
avion aux formes étranges attend le feu
vert pour décoller il est presque sept
heures du matin sur la base militaire de
payerne en suisse dans la salle de
contrôle
la tension est palpable c'est l'heure
le pilote andré borschberg mettant route
les quatre moteurs électriques
uniquement alimenté par les 12000
cellules solaires posés sur les ailes à
35 kilomètres heure seulement l'avion
décolle sous les yeux des admirateurs
décollage était pas les conditions météo
sont idéales qui fonctionne en tout cas
jusqu'à maintenant on croise les doigts
car on avance dans l'inconnu et à rien
n'est certain
jusqu'au bout on sait pas ce qui peut
arriver
oui solarim pulse est le premier avion a
tenté de voler 25 heures de jour comme
de nuit sans carburant pour charger les
batteries et à recompter la nuit il doit
monter à 8500 mètres
le pilote est confiant c'est vraiment un
moment spécial très important toute
l'équipe attend ça depuis le début
depuis presque sept ans si tout se passe
bien cela rime punch devrait entamer un
tour du monde en 2013
s l'avion du futur ni carburant ni
pollution depuis ce matin solarim paul
survolent la suisse
le test est important ils tentent de
voler 25 à 27 heures d'affilée y compris
donc la nuit nicolas chateauneuf un vol
qui défie l'imagination quand solarim
pulse d'école ce matin c'est pour battre
un record celui du plus long vol sans
autre carburant que les rayons du soleil
capturé par les immenses ailes au moins
25 heures dans le ciel
jour et nuit à bord du cockpit le pilote
savoure l'instant
c'est vraiment un moment spécial très
important toute l'équipe attend ça
depuis le début depuis presque sept ans
et on le comprend car l'avion est un
condensé d'innovation sa structure en
fibre de carbone lui permet d'avoir des
ailes aussi large qu'un airbus a340 tout
en limitant le poids à celui d'une
voiture sur les ailes 12 lille cellules
solaires fournissent l'électricité aux
batteries et aux quatre moteurs
tout est est testée et prouvée conçu
pour alléger l'ensemble même le cockpit
du pilote a été soumis au plus rude
épreuve actuellement l'avion vole à huit
mille deux cents mètres d'altitude au
dessus de la suisse
les conditions météo sont excellentes
les batteries chargées avant d'affronter
la nuit se croise les doigts on avance
dans l'inconnu
rien n'est certain à 100 anglaise
jusqu'au bout on sait pas ce qui peut
arriver
we dance si tout se passe bien sûr la
rime punch devrait tenter le tour du
monde en 2013
une nouvelle alerte à la